morning Millennials welcome back to the
morning toast happy Friday Friday gotta
get down on Friday and happy birthday
birthday gotta get down I'm a birthday I
just feel so old
and so depressed and this is gonna be
the worst birthday yet and I'm okay with
that I just I was having this
conversation last night you see if a
good attitude about it yeah you know
life is all about having a good attitude
I'm just like I have no plans for the
future I have no plans for my 26 year
I'm just I am now at the point in my
life where if somebody asks me how old I
am
I will take that as an insult like and I
will no longer be saying my age and if
I'm forced to I will say 23 okay do you
but you have to do I understand now like
women who get offended like how old are
you no that's literally me yeah well I
mean hopefully things will turn around
soon and you'll have plans for your 26th
year your big dreams and your big goals
yeah no for sure
all the fabulosity will be in store for
you well hope that you have a happy
birthday I don't know how we can turn
the frown upside down
today but we're gonna try well I
apologize for being so pessimistic I am
incredibly hungover from you know I had
a few let's good news yes it's it's a
little new news I had like a small you
know a few drinks a couple shots you
know with some friends last night which
was nice like I was gonna ring in my
birthday like sad and in my bed watching
the crown I started the crown you guys
yeah very sad should watch Wow
ringing content so Ben was like do you
want to like have a drink and I was like
sure and then the night just kind of
took itself from there
and it was fun I'm glad that I'm
hungover but like I'm just I'm miserable
right now like I'm so nauseous and I'm
so old and like the combo was really
hitting me
well you look quite fabulous today in
your windbreaker I was like coming on
the ha sick is that wind bringing broken
right and it was you and thank you for
your service but also you really do look
great and you should feel great
you know since you're hungover I guess
I'll have to be like extra funny perky
and okay um but you know what that is my
birthday gift to you along with the
gifts that I got you which I think
you'll really like I'm excited for gifts
and then you know I'm really excited for
cake and to be honest if I know you and
like you didn't send some sort of speed
to treat to my house today like consider
yourself disowned and to yourself
unknown yeah like I I really like to
look forward to like the baked by
melissa is that I'm assuming are gonna
be waiting for me when I get home but
like if I get home and there's no
cupcakes like I just want to say like I
will be upset you guys I I mean I
believe in the people around you to do
those things for you but like now if
anyone watching is someone who's close
enough to know Claudius I dress can you
please send some [ __ ] and I'll give you
my credit card number you know if mo you
please send I also like if I work with
you like you know flowers are nice but
like cupcakes are appreciated I just I
can't stress that enough I feel like I
should have said that earlier it's maybe
last week that people could have
prepared she said be home for like an
hour at least so if you know her well
enough to know her address please send
something of n mo you we got you ears
got you covered the only thing that can
make me you know happy on this terrible
birthday is sweets sweets can cheer up
any day and Olivia when we over when we
went over to Olivia's house she had so
many shitty how many feet so but I don't
get just as many or more than I love you
like I'm gonna cry okay we will get on
the sweets train for you okay I'm
actually gonna be home and maybe a
little bit more than an hour because I'm
thinking of after this treating myself
to a pedicure well speaking of I'm so
glad you brought that up because I
treated myself yesterday to a pedicure
it was really the one skill I was unable
to master in quarantine and let me just
tell you it was phenomenal tip though I
didn't know you have to make an
appointment before you go oh no I showed
up and they were I kept to make an
appointment site like made an
appointment for came back later yeah so
I just came back worth it it was so
fabulous I didn't get a manicure because
I do find manicures to be a little
stressful and I've been enjoying them
doing them on my own
also because all of my nails are broken
and I don't want to show up until
they're back to their healthy states
they could be like loud yes right now
and I've had them know I'm like I'm
really need a manicure but to me that is
something that is like so so much in
exchange of germs you said so close to
no I mean where the artists where I went
it was so it was so well done
every place is like that they take your
temperature they make you sign in say if
you've been near anyone who's been
exposed to Kovan each pedicure seat has
a plastic partition in between and the
manicure table has a plastic partition
in between the manicurist and the
manicure and you just show them your
hands and then sanitizer everywhere it's
I really felt safe
I brought my book I was very relaxed it
was very nice
okay the only fun thing for you to do
today yep because I'm gonna get like an
extra 10-minute foot massage like I have
been dying for a massage in quarantine
like that has been the one thing that
like I just can't live without and I
don't even get massages that often but I
just get some tents or something
yeah and I'm going to get like a little
foot rub and that's what I'm really
excited about that will be like the rim
on top of my creme pie the cherry on top
yeah that's what I was gonna say yeah no
worries
before we get into everything how are
you feeling about the crown should we
pay for TV recap segment
um no because I'm like barely I've
really not made enough progress I think
I'm on like a pisode seven of the first
season and hear my thoughts my thoughts
are I'm really not look into history nor
do I have like an extensive knowledge of
let alone American but British history
like I'm just not that smart you know so
I do find myself lost many time but do
you find yourself interested in curious
yes of course
like the glamour honestly I don't really
care about like the Parliament and like
the Prime Minister stuff but I do like
live for like the royalty and the gossip
and the brother who had to abdicate the
throne like that little [ __ ] like I like
the dorama
um and it's actually really smart like
like they need a TV show like a drama
about a TV show like what's more
dramatic than the royal family like it's
funny how it's like a show but like it's
real you Matt and I look it it's fine
like Prince Phillip is a [ __ ] and I
can't stand him in he does not support
women like you could get that vibe from
him immediately 100% but you know like
he comes around but the first two
seasons are really rough for him the
first season is really selling general
so if you're able to stick with it
you'll only like it more and more I
don't just like it it starts to move
even faster and every episode is really
like a cultural moment that you
we know about not all of them but then
the ones that I didn't know about like
the landside them you'll see um it was
just like devastating and an interesting
piece of history so I quiet found it all
quite interesting yeah that's good I
mean literally the girl Claire Foy looks
just like Queen Elizabeth did when she
was a child I'm like we know it's know
what I find so interesting I get like I
have a weird sense of time so this is
the 50s and to me like the 50s is
forever ago but like it's really not and
like they were able to tell a vice or
carnation and like they get paparazzi to
everywhere they go but it's like I
literally thought paparazzi's were like
a 20-year old thing yeah well it's a
different sort of paparazzi but yeah it
is it's the modern age yeah and she
really ushered us into the modern era
and for that she's a queen you have no
choice but to stand we Nev I she's so
little like even in the show like her
little vibe is really perfectly
portrayed but she's such a great Queen
and you'll continue to see that yeah and
then you'll understand why some of us
Royalists we're just so upset by what my
Harry and Megan did I understand one
thing it's like I was really sad when
her dad died but like I couldn't deal
with the coughing anymore like it was
bothering me it was so gross like and
having to watch him like cough up blood
and like put those dirty napkins like in
his bedside box like it was so nasty so
even though I was sad to see him go I
was not sad for like the coughing to
stop I don't recall there being so oh my
god so much coughing and like it was the
kind of cough where like you literally
think the person's gonna die like Oh
have you ever seen the King's Speech no
I thought maybe that you had but the
King's Speech is about her dad Oh Colin
Firth is her dad yes yeah and it's about
his um transition into power
when his brother abdicated got it got it
got it got it
so if you ever like really got into it
that would be a good thing to watch next
got it okay like I can only think of
people as how they're related to Queen
Elizabeth like all the other like I
can't the familial relations and like
the family tree and the ancestry is too
complicated I'm like who are you to
Elizabeth yeah I mean that's how it
works so like who are you to Elizabeth
and the further you got like the less
relevant you are yeah
and also like it's no wonder why like
nobody likes Charles you know because
like he
was really raised by Philip who was also
like a man who didn't support women
you'll see it's it's interesting
Charles's upbringing and has he been
born yet even yeah yeah
is he in school I'm sure he is but I
haven't seen you at school
he's school but I assume me is the best
education oh okay school becomes a big
topic for discussion and you're gonna
see different side to Charles okay and
at first at first tea sweet nan he's
sour okay well actually I do like it and
that's what I'll be doing today if you
want to feel that for me yes it comes
honestly now that we're going back down
memory lane uh it sounds like a great
day yeah no it's not something Theo's
there and he's just looking so cute Theo
is here he's here but he's asleep he
decided to fall asleep off-camera which
is so [ __ ] rude which is so rude
biggis he just kind of wanted to be out
of the limelight today he's like let's
focus on mom it's her day okay that's
actually very sweet of him ya know he
knows like obviously everyone's gonna
stare at him when he's in frame yeah
it's so true but he was like mom put on
her fancy woman breakers she did
everyone look at her it's a big day for
mom okay that all she wrote before she
started writing the next paragraph no by
the way it's not at all all she wrote
because we let her have a whole show
before she started writing the next
paragraph
I guess she's pressing enter she's
pressing enter tab because now it's time
for the past five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast and as
promised today's Friday which means we
are going to be highlighting a
black-owned business and I'm really
excited about today's because it is true
nude founded by deny pointer true nude
is a personalized sustainable
undergarment brand that women can wear
comfortably and confidently as a black
woman it was always impossible for deny
to find her shade of nude but also with
the 32 GG bra she needed to be able to
find her size on the rack tonight was
always self-conscious about her body and
she always wanted to find a way to
reclaim her body and help other women
who felt the same way to feel confident
in their own skin deny found true nude
and moved to LA from Brooklyn in 2017 to
be closer to the production true nude is
made of luxurious bamboo fabrics sourced
locally in LA and made by a badass team
of women true nude offers a variety of
undergarments and
has a simple three-step process select
your garment pick your skin tone and
finalize your order once you select a
style of your choice you can upload a
photo of yourself to find your own shade
of nude deny has founded a brand where
every shade of nude exists and where
every women can women can feel
comfortable and confident in their body
they are currently selling out of shades
but are working on restocking as quickly
as possible to shop all Styles fill find
your own shade of nude and to receive
15% off your first order visit my true
neucom and use the code welcome 15 so
the link is my true nude my TR u n UD e
dot-com and use code welcome 15 that's
welcome 1/5 you can also find them on
Instagram at true nude love it ok let's
get into the stories her first story is
an ongoing story from yesterday very
very sad an update on Naya Rivera police
say they quote don't know if they will
find her body it's a complicated search
as the search for Naya Rivera continues
police say they don't know if the
actress's body will be recovered during
a press conference on Thursday
addressing Rivera's disappearance
Ventura County Sheriff's Office sergeant
Devan Kevin Donahue said quote if the
body is entangled in something
underneath the water it may never come
up we don't know he added due to the
conditions of Lake Piru Donahue said the
search for Rivera is complicated he
explained that at this time the
visibility of the lake is not very good
it's terrible quote there's a lot of
trees and plants and such that are under
the water that can cause entanglement
makes it unsafe for divers and a
complicated search he said ahead of the
press conference police told People
magazine that they are confident that
Rivera is still in the water as because
at this time there's no evidence that
she made it to shore holy [ __ ] I mean I
literally I feel like this story is just
like shaken in the world because
everyone's whether you're like a mom or
you're just like just sympathetic it's
just such a freak accident um and it's
just so sad I mean I'm such a cleave and
it's just devastating yeah it's really
sad so she's been presumed dead yes it's
it's a recovery mission not a rescue
mission yes some reason we can sell prey
and hope for a miracle
but this is just extremely sad and I
feel like it happened so fast like all
the information like came out so fast -
well I think it's because it happened
like in the late in the very early
morning so it was all day yesterday and
crazier just keeping us updated but her
son has been reunited with his father
which is great I'm just the kid oh my
god just can you imagine like what I saw
no I can't I can't really really sad and
I just I'm so sad I'm so sad we're still
thinking and and praying for her family
at this time and praying for a miracle
um a miracle that's what we need mm-hmm
next story some happy news okay Jesse
Tyler Ferguson and Justin Makita
welcomed their first child together
welcome to the modern family baby
Beckett Jesse Tyler Ferguson and lawyer
thank you ma'am
yeah Justin maketo welcomed their first
child together the actors rep confirmed
to page six on Thursday quote Jessie and
Justin welcomed their little bundle of
joy
Beckett Mercer Ferguson Makita July 11th
2020 olivia has a new birthday buddy
Beckett Mercer Ferguson Makita okay the
new parents are overjoyed and excited
for this new journey as a family of
three beautiful beautiful happy for them
even they're a little thirsty on
Instagram but like I'll allow it
yeah so Cherno and i can light a judge
now that obviously a lot of industries
are on pause everyone's taking to
Instagram to get out and to thirsts out
and honestly just to like occupy their
time of course Becky that's a very cute
name though it is a cute name I've been
like very in tune with sub-routine Eames
now I feel like for the last year just
like thinking cuz now like you know
there's babies happening and so I'm like
what our good name you know what are you
thinking um you don't wanna share Shayla
oh no I wouldn't
I will not share Shayla I will not share
Shayla walked so we could run yeah see
she taught us a lesson that was an
important lesson from Sex in the City
I mean I feel like I could have figured
that out but it was good that everyone
learned it oh great yeah okay next story
something we've been talking about and I
if this was already news but it's the
first time I'm hearing about it victims
are sharing horror stories in the first
look at surviving Jeffrey Epstein show a
trailer for lifetimes two night special
surviving Jeffrey Epstein has been
exclusively shared with the post much
like the Network special surviving our
Kelly the documentary will feature
several in-depth interviews with women
who claim to have been trafficked by
Epstein the for our special will will
air Sunday August 9th at 8:00 p.m. and
Monday August 10th at 9 p.m. exactly one
year after the pedophile was found dead
in his Manhattan jail cell thank you for
not saying that he killed himself right
quote being abused by Jeffrey Epstein is
a life sentence one woman says in the
video clip he was enjoying violating me
I'm going to fight back says another so
this is what we were just saying a
documentary on Netflix and we were
hopeful that another one would come out
because you felt as though justice was
not served I felt like we were robbed in
a lot of ways as it pertained to the
real connections Jeffrey Epstein made in
Hollywood in politics in business in
global affairs
so obviously this sounds good but this
is also not really what I was missing
but who knows what they'll do lifetime
does a good job honestly normally I roll
my eyes at lifetime it's like everything
they do like that we're in Harry and
Megan movie like is so tacky but they
did a phenomenal job with our Kelly and
I think that I trust them too to do
justice for these girls I agree I think
um this will be a very powerful
documentary I look forward to watching
it and lifetime I'm here for lifetime
you know it's it's good stuff and oh I'm
part of a lifetime Movie Club it's so
fabulous like dramas oh it's chilling
stuff I mean lifetime when I was a kid
life time was like these like
overdramatized like murder thrillers
boiler alert still is really I thought
now it's like Hallmark vibes so okay
they kind of get their dip their toe in
a lot of different fields and I think
their bread and butter is always those
like lifetime murder mysteries you know
woman gone girl situation yeah like you
know watered down yeah girl so they that
they've been doing that for a while
during the Christmas season they do try
to come for hallmarks crown and you know
what I am just appreciative of more
Christmas movies so I'm not gonna say
anything and then actually I know I've
spoken about it
many times on the show but was it on
lifetime I saw a lifetime Christmas
movie starring Mayim Bialik that
literally ruined my life yeah no it
clearly it clearly cause some
devastation for you because I don't know
if you're able to go like a month
without talking about it I'm not I mean
I'm literally so triggered right I'm not
I'm not able to go Thank You lifetime
for ruining Christmas movies for her
yeah um and then also they do this
serious work like the one that they did
with surviving r.kelly and so I know
then they also have the other layer of
weird celebrity biopics where like they
do the Britney it's so strange they did
add Nicole Smith I caught that one
that's like the Megan and Harry thing
yet that it's like a community theater
it's so bad yeah it's definitely
community theater vibes yeah it's so
strange you know it's such a weird and
like they're widely reported like
casting has been set for and like nobody
cares no it's a you're always hearing
about it yeah that's really true they
need to pick a lane yeah two lanes you
know because homework does have movies
and mysteries as well
and those TV shows ya know they so they
do two different things because they do
they're like classic love story but then
they also do a little spooky stuff on
the movies and mysteries Channel
oh yeah well no they have a channel for
yeah I'm just saying cuz it was big
business big business
so anyways August 9th and 10th surviving
Jeffrey Epstein will be on lifetime
check it out I'm always I'm always happy
to support something that furthers the
Jeffrey Epstein narrative like I just
wanted to ever be forgotten I completely
agree next story very sad Robert DeNiro
says coronavirus has decimated his
finances Robert DeNiro says he's running
out of dinero the Korean virus that is
funny the post this page sex funny oh
those funny the crew know they are they
have like their headlines rep the
coronavirus dealt a massive blow to the
actors finances he revealed in court as
his estranged wife asked for an
emergency order to raise her monthly
American Express card credit limit from
50,000 to $100,000 the irishman actor
appeared on a Skype call in his
Manhattan
divorce case with grace Hightower as her
lawyer told a judge at DeNiro unfairly
cut her monthly Amex allowance from a
hundred thousand to fifty thousand and
said she and their children had been
banned from an upstate compound where
DeNiro is staying during the pandemic
but lawyers for De Niro said he cut
Hightower's credit card limit because
he's taken a huge financial hit as the
restaurant chain Nobu and Greenwich
Hotel both of which he has stakes in
have been closed or partially closed for
months with barely any business wait I
didn't know he owned a piece in Nobu
yeah no this is really interesting
Antony Rose lawyer told the judge that
Nobu lost three million dollars in April
and another one point eight seven
million dollars in May and he had to pay
investors five hundred thousand dollars
on a capital call which he borrowed
money from his business partners to make
because he doesn't have the cash his
lawyer said I'm sorry robert de niro
doesn't have five hundred thousand
dollars he's doing something wrong well
I mean it's keep listening because it is
interesting there's nobody even though
in in a divorce proceeding he's
obviously trying to make it look like he
has way less money than he does because
he doesn't want to fork it over yes but
this is an old divorce like he had to
cut his um checks to his ex-wife and now
the ex-wife is like why couldn't he's
not making the money that he used to
make he shouldn't necessarily be paying
what he used to pay okay but like he
definitely has like a nice sum of money
from all the movies over the years you
don't think he's the way or else to
explain that under the terms of their
2004 prenuptial agreement Robert De
Niro's only required to pay Hightower 1
million dollars a year as long as he's
making fifteen million dollars or more
in income and if his income declines his
payments to her proportionally do so to
his account some business managers say
that the best case for mr. De Niro is if
everything starts to turn around this
year he's going to be lucky if he makes
7.5 million this year oh we're totally
gonna make 7 million dollars this is
such a dumb story like I'm sorry I don't
feel bad for you Robert De Niro like
we're like if you're gonna be in this
bit Robert De Niro is one of the most
successful actors of all time has been
in some of the highest-grossing movies
of all time and like he can't figure out
how to be child support please his
lawyer said that these people in spite
of his robust earnings have always spent
more than he has earned so the 76 year
old robust man couldn't retire even if
he want
because he can't afford to keep up with
his lifestyle expenses oh the poor old
rich man can't retire why am I not sad
like at all sorry we're in an economic
crisis and this is so out of touch like
I can't even begin to scratch a service
on what's wrong with this story like
sorry I literally like here's the thing
this is me not feeling bad for Robert De
Niro no no sympathy for mr. in the air
from you know to the man who's making
seven and a half million dollars this
year no there is none
I'm for me you can search your elsewhere
check out another Morning Show look for
a little sympathy from them because it
ain't gonna be me okay I think yeah like
really Robert now like read the room
Robert okay well when a national
economic crisis millions of people
unemployed Instagram was like feel sorry
for like this is just what we do I know
from the courts you know obviously he's
having a rough go of it right now I just
I hope to be in in a place in my life
when I'm 97 or however old he is
aye aye 76 I really hope to be in a
place where like on a bad year I make
seven and a half million dollars that's
really all one can hope for
there was also an interesting factoid in
the article that he already got paid for
the Irishman
um and am I like lady we just get paid
2.5 million dollars from that in 2020
and 2021 that's kind of low yeah that is
kind of low I thought so too
yeah maybe like I feel like certainly as
you do as I prestige not for the money
whereas like he did the in turn for the
money you know yeah even though it's a
fabulous man one of his best
one of his best I couldn't agree more
okay fifth and final story Shannon
beador ex-husband David beador is
expecting a baby with his fiancee and we
need a wellness check on China
yeah we do the ex-husband of Real
Housewives of Orange County star Shannon
beador is expecting a child with his
fiancee Leslie cook cook revealed the
news on her private Instagram story with
footage of a bun in the oven and Ed
Sheeran small bump playing in the
background she also posted a tick tocks
you know what that song is about small
bump I just want to let you know she
also posted a tick tock video telling
her daughter the news wow she sounds
thursday-night young
um she said she's going to be a big
sister can you believe it are you
excited are you excited show me how
excited you are
well I came live in mr. tick-tock it
sounds amazing whatever happy for them I
just think like Shannon's gonna be
really unwell from this and I really
need her because it's one thing for like
your ex-husband and the father of your
children to move on with another woman
but it really changes the game when that
person has a child yeah yeah also dude
was always hot yeah but he's so mean no
like his insides aren't hot but his
outsides hot yeah but at a certain point
the insides start to affect the outsides
of course in both no in a good and a bad
way like even fabulous inside like it
really makes you hot a hundred percent a
hundred percent
I'm also Judas he Francesca farrago from
too hot to handle I don't know why I
just thought of this she flew to Dallas
for like some work stuff and she was
having lunch or dinner with Jamie like a
bunch of people but Damien from love is
blind was there like the two Netflix
shows oh interesting but is he still
with Giannina she might have been there
but I couldn't say I I don't know
they Giannina and Damien and just like a
lot of those people from love is blind
became so famous and so relevant like in
the blink of an eye yeah now that
Francesca's single I've been like
wondering what her next move is gonna be
in comments on her Instagram she
comments on his I think that that could
be some there could be something brewing
there and I was I'm sure she's just been
like sitting while she was in a
relationship and I think she was really
committed to her relationship and never
really like looked elsewhere elsewhere
but I'm sure she like had the thought
like oh wow a big star now who could I
date right five million followers the
tip Louis coming to my Instagram she the
most beautiful woman in the world
now she's also hanging out with Tana
mojo in LA like she's really she's
getting places that I'm like loving it
also they'd made like such a cute chick
talk they've been hanging out Tana mojo
and Francesca and they made out in one
and I kind of ship them now so we'll say
cute yeah that's funny that you said the
Diplo thing to it now makes me feel like
there's definitely a ship like because
it's it's an every photo it's not just
one that he comments like consistently
he's commenting on every single one of
her photos
Wow okay that's a couple to me honestly
that's a people who are DMA and have
something funny going on and like the
comments are like you know nods back to
inside jokes that they made me a DM yes
no I really [ __ ]
I guess they're engaged Wow Jenny will
be admitted to the wedding No
um IPTV recap segment we're gonna talk
about Real Housewives of New York which
was back again after oh no it was that
last week but we didn't we didn't recap
last week so we'll just talk about the
whole thing in general I mean let's talk
about the Halloween party first because
that was last week yeah so drunk to Rina
mean that awful host and she did did
something amazing
she actually managed to make me feel bad
firm on a singer which has literally
never happened in my life I felt so bad
for her it was so uncomfortable I don't
know how these women continue to forget
each other how is Sonja Ramona and
Dorinda are like the best of friends yet
they hurt each other in the most
egregious egregious ways every week that
[ __ ] behavior from Sonja Morgan I
hadn't seen ever like it was insane I
never saw someone so drunk in my life
ya know it was wild she was being funny
Leah looked amazing nice OH I mean she
looks amazing but yes she looks stellar
jealous when Sonja um gets drunk and
like it's at her at her most drunk like
she's still so sweet and funny and loved
more was harmless other people venom
that [ __ ] speech to be so triggered
by Ramona being like are you drunk like
was 17 and honestly I don't agree with
doing that at all of course remotest
problematic in her own ways but like
you're all bent out of shape because she
made you because you don't because
Ramona doesn't want to share her
birthday party with Sonja yeah like I
know it's trivial cuz like they're 60
year old women fighting Reppert they
parties but like Ramona's planning a
party for her birthday like why does it
have to include Sonja also when i
rewatch the scene and Ramona says are
you drunk it's right wind arenas like
really up in her face and I'm sure
Ramona just smelled alcohol it was like
oh are you drunk that's why you're
talking I'm sorry like Oh someone
thinking Durand is drunk at a party it's
not the craziest thing ever she always
is also it's like Halloween it's a big
soiree why wouldn't you be drunk yeah
you know I I just and also during the is
two different people when she stronger
when she sold her so asking that
question like really does change the
tone of the conversation do I need to
take this seriously or not right we got
a Jill Zarin cameo which was nice we did
I like her yeah I like her too it's
always nice to see I don't know if I
want like her to make a return like I
wouldn't be opposed to it but I just I
like seeing her yeah
it's a nod back to like when some
things were simpler I don't think it
makes sense right now because I do think
we need to head in the direction of like
more Lea's yes and unless Dorinda and
Ramona what were your thoughts ammonia
what are your thoughts on the zoom
confessionals okay so you had really got
me hyped up about that they were
terrible
I thought Lea's was nearly perfect in
terms of the echo of her audio working
with just Confessional it was about oh I
don't care about that round I really
cared about the audio because yeah it
just went I felt like I was watching a
YouTube video when you're watching all
these different clips put together in a
vlog and the audio was different every
time and then someone comes music over
enemy I have to keep changing my volume
yeah
Luann's audio was atrocious like worse
than anything I've ever heard I thought
that Ramona and Sonja's was pretty good
and I also liked the fact that they were
able to give good interviews despite the
fact that it's not as like glamorous as
it was Toni looked amazing Sonia looked
amazing so it didn't totally I got I got
kind of used to it but every time
Luann's came on because sometimes the
confessionals play in the background
while we're watching yesyes and it's
like you must don't know what you're
listening to and so some of the women
have really good confessionals and I
mean Luann's really brought down the
group average Elise has a confessional
what is going on with her I was sitting
in her foyer like in front of her front
door it's the weirdest thing she's not a
housewife I think she had a similar
experience Jerry barber okay where it's
like we think you're interesting let's
give you a camera we gave you a camera
there's nothing interesting about you
even though she is really involved in
the drama she's just so lame like every
time she does something I just cringe
and want to die like even her fighting
with Ramona it was just so what kind of
like she was acting and then she let me
sit in lab look and it's like she's
fighting with Ramona and it seems like
at least it's really in the right she's
probably a very good friend Ramona the
this her telling about Ramona like
taking off her cover up in fact like I
can't even tell you how much that grinds
my gears like I just do not [ __ ] with
people like the [ __ ] with people like
that at all so she's totally and right
but when they're fighting in the
berkshires I'm like leave Ramona oh no
totally because to me it's just like at
least might be upset about what's going
on but she's just really like knowing
for a storyline and I it's too obvious
for me you know but even if you are in
the right like if you can't drive your
point home and make your argument like
succinctly and correctly you've lost me
I only have so much time for like dinner
pies I agree um I think that during this
house looks amazing stunning I mean
maybe it's because I have quarantine
eyes also in addition to all of the
revamps that she did but you know what
when we saw the first scene of her there
and then like three minutes later she
says she talks about how she got
Richards stuff out and the energy feels
lighter I was like I could feel the
energy from my TV like yeah it's so much
lighter and brighter it's so beautiful
there she did such a beautiful judgment
beautiful um I'm really happy for her
that she got it all in check and and
that she's feeling lighter about
everything because it was obviously
wetting her down and that affected her
relationships with everyone and
everything and so I I was very happy to
see all of that come to fruition and you
know what else was interesting about
last night's episode for the first time
in a while I think Luo man was strong
yeah because she was being insane at the
end okay but also she must be I I
haven't been watching whether or not
she's drinking when the women were
having rose' with those amazing balls of
ice yes some of those I wasn't sure I
didn't look to see if she was drinking
but then when she talks to Sohn yelling
she's a drunk person and when she was
talking to Ramona at the end oh and
she's just like looking like they just
know so I wonder if she's drinking with
the women or like secretly secretly I
feel like she's drinking with the women
okay um that was really sad to watch
yeah because so much of me wants to
believe and really did think that like
she really didn't have a problem with
alcohol it was just like she got herself
in a bad situation
oh no no because I feel like maybe she's
just drunk there in the berkshires like
it's safe in the same way that during
the gets up and starts talking and like
is speaking nonsense so yeah everyone's
drunk so like she's ought to be drunk
but like what she was saying to Sonja
who was so sweet and so supportive and
like really only ever been a good friend
to her it doesn't have a mean bone in
her body was so rude and also at the end
of the day she should be paying Sonya of
course I'm Sonya I get a higher like
unfortunately this is the world that we
live in where yes she's not trained on
Broadway you're a reality TV star and
you're showing up to perform somewhere
like you are going to be paid more than
someone who's a Broadway trained actor
or comedian or dancer
it's the industry it's the industry and
it's it's I think that LuAnn in a lot of
ways things she's doing Sonja a favor by
letting her come on the show and I could
see how she would think that like LuAnn
really has built something really
impressive like her show was very
successful I got picked up by Live
Nation but to just disregard Sonja and
like not even acknowledge the fact like
she's actually doing you a favor too it
was disappointing
yeah and it was very disappointing the
women were shocked to hear and I think
that's kind of we even had this
discussion when they were rehearsing
together I was like is she paying her I
hope she's paying her and then it came
you said that she was paying her $250
which doesn't even cover hair and makeup
I'm sure amongst the women they had
these questions like what is she paying
her should be 5,000 and should be 10,000
when she was like 250 and Ramona's like
you mean 2,250 and she's like no 215
like I think it was very interesting for
the women to hear that because she is
being taken advantage of so again and
the fact that she even needs to ask her
to be paid more like just then you
should pay her I agree if she's being
taken advantage of yes it yeah and so
that was sad to watch
especially like watching LuAnn dig in
like all everyone these mean names but
that is probably because she's drunk
hopefully but next week up and and
she'll feel differently about it yeah I
just like honestly really enjoyed
watching them in the BerkShares it just
looks like such a fun cozy weekend like
I really wanted to be there yeah Farm
chiming vibes like watching it in
quarantine makes it all the more sweet
so sad and jealous but the house really
it did look stellar and what else was
that it pretty much it yeah I was boring
episode otherwise but I don't want you
anything else last night I was drunk oh
I almost done with my book it's called
the second home and its really good so
if you're looking for a nice a nice read
I reckon we're always looking for a nice
raid I think you may like it okay um
anything else before we wrap and I go
throw up
well I think you have to sing happy
birthday crossing it but I just don't
want to hurt your head any more than I'm
at Dennis but before you do that we're
just gonna wait for sweet treats for you
sweetie sweets are sweet as
meet in here for you oh my god sweets
wow what a nice cake oh my goodness
I would happily sing to myself oh wow
this is so cute thank you guys ready say
[Music]
princess happy birthday and to my Queen
Jessica Simpson and Erika Jayne my
birthday Queens
happy birthday Jessica Simpson Erika
Jayne and Claudia ASHRAE it's good yes
let's start the day off with some sweets
I love sweets thank you for my cake
thank you everyone for the birthday
wishes in advance and the greeting cards
and the cakes and the cards and flowers
it's so sweet to be the son well we'd
love you puppy hope you have a great day
as good as possible yeah Theodora do you
want to wish your mother a happy
birthday
he wants cake he wants cake first it
could literally kill him oh for sure so
no cake for tea oh thank you guys so
much for listening to the morning toast
Monday morning you do it thank you guys
so much for those things to the morning
toast the millennium morning show we
post videos on YouTube every morning
sometime in the morning Monday through
Friday around 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time
but you never know so if you want to
keep up with us follow us on Instagram
at the morning toes to like us on
YouTube subscribe to us in the podcast
app watch us on Spotify anywhere you
listen to podcasts iTunes stitcher
Public Radio I Heart Radio casts socks
all the places thank you so much for
listening to the morning toast so ever
you listen to us wherever you listen to
us make sure to leave a five-star review
about how beautiful stunning and smart
we are we will see you on Monday bye
have a good weekend stay safe